I think the scheme is the story of a
hustle of everyone hustling each other
everybody had an intention which is why
it's called the scheme everybody was
plotting and scheming and planning
against each other without knowing that
the other party was doing it the same
thing okay so Taylor rugs here with
Christian Dawkins who is the centerpiece
of HBO's new documentary the scheme
which follows him throughout this
college basketball corruption scandal
was charged with wire fraud bribery my
maximum sentence was 200 years what
so Christian I guess my first question
would just be is there anything that you
want to set straight with this
documentary the biggest thing for myself
were doing it was just trying to paint a
better picture of the overall story and
make people understand why I did when I
did it maybe they won't understand it
but at least you'll see another point of
view of why everything went down the way
it went down so those are the things
that we have to be honest and Exce
ourselves when you're watching a
documentary is it fair it is what what's
happening really that corruption is in
other industries is what's happening in
the documentary even a problem I'm in
the music business now what I'm doing in
the documentary is being a good manager
that's just business on a Tuesday in
college sports is the [ __ ] it's now a
felony in all it all stems back to the
same systemic problems of society and
that's why the documentary to me is a
sports family it's deeper than that
because the same problems that are going
on in average in people's everyday lives
are the same thing that's happening in
this documentary sports this just be the
the focus or basketball was just the
focus but it's the same problems that go
on in America every day you know
basketball agency world Christian is
like a master model for a young guy
incredibly well-connected he wanted
money to run a sports agency so I think
what it will do is is not so much this
isn't a story where I was trying to
necessarily get redemption or some kind
of validation from from from people
outside of my circle the biggest thing
was just to to tell a bigger story and
to and to make everybody understand the
why basically
Christian had no idea Jeff D'Angelo was
an FBI agent trying to build and coaches
bribery case listen bro this guy's
stupid gets going here I'm gonna take
the money and keep it in the beginning
slate of the documentary there's this
quote something to the effect of nine
out of ten teens are cheating the tip
last place correct you agree I think
that quote is really trying to say is if
you don't have the best you're probably
gonna lose and to get the best you're
probably gonna have to do what needs to
be done it's best they said to me we
want you to give us Rick Pitino Sean
Miller the head coach in Arizona will
weigh - head coach at Louisiana State
University the whole thing was
manufactured the whole thing was
arguably entrapment someone's preventing
information for being out there this is
bigger than me what do you think this
documentary will mean for will Wade and
Sean Miller so for me I don't want
anything to happen to them I think it
would be that would again further the
problem with the whole situation I would
hope and pray that that nothing happens
to any coach out of this and I would
hope everybody nothing happens to any
player out of this that that's not my
point that's not what I'm trying to get
if I wanted to expose or to get somebody
in trouble I could have easily just
cooperated with the government and those
guys wouldn't even be coaching right now
that ain't the point but I think because
the roots are in place everybody has to
operate in this secret or
under-the-table manner and and when that
happens our case happened well thank you
so much for showing you where a pleasure
the documentary is fantastic you guys
did a great job I wish you two backs you
certainly are a hustler have a great one
I'm Stacey all the things but I
appreciate your time I appreciate you
too thank you thanks did you do anything
wrong Christian did I do anything wrong
[Music]